little lost today I find that a lot of
people they want to achieve results but
they're not willing to commit to that
educational side of things yeah to read
a book go to a class go to a seminar you
know come to a crash course you know all
these things are so important I mean I'm
sitting in front of you I didn't finish
school I didn't go to no university no
rich mama no rich daddy you know and
everything that I've created like you
said making millions in business you
know having the financial success that I
have today it all came through self
education knowing that I was intended to
do great things but if I didn't open up
the book if I didn't take the seminar if
I didn't take the course I would never
achieve it and Robert Kiyosaki kind of
put me on that path of asking questions
understanding that there's more than the
9:00 to 5:00 9:00 to 5:00 until you're
65 yeah and so this is what I love the
commonality of sitting with you
obviously we spend dated today together
you know looking at deals looking at
properties but also understanding that
there's so many cool ways to make money
other than being that slave
yeah and property is a great way to live
leverage our energies problems because
the massive problems here's the thing
all I was thinking when I'm 18 I'm gonna
buy a house and I was 17 and I was
getting more all these training courses
and I was learning how to do it I was
thinking as soon as I'm 18 I'm gonna do
a no money down deal and I'd learnt the
strategies and then my mortgage broker
told me you've got to be 21 to get by to
let mortgage so I'm like I'm not waiting
for years so I found a solution which
was to put my property in someone else's
name in the family they're almost like a
guarantor and then I thought what if I'm
gonna do that why even wait till I'm 18
why not just do it now at 17 and a
massive obstacle that could have held me
about four years actually enabled me to
start immediately and I think that
that's just flipping the cards it's
funny you say they're flipping the cards
you know we you know one of the things
that I teach in some of the programs
that I that I that I you know share and
travel around the world teaching people
how to achieve financial freedom
it's always about perspective where one
person sees crisis the other person sees
opportunity and you know it's really
about changing the way you look at
things where some people would see that
as a downfall and say
got a certain went along 21 go get a job
work it out and in reality gets stuck
into that lifestyle and eventually
possibly never get a property you saw
that as okay there's a problem here's
the situation
I see this as an opportunity you use it
as fuel to move you forward I think
that's so cool and as funny you say that
you had problems because I feel that a
lot of people they have problems but
they have problems but they don't have
enough pain
yeah sure and I think if people had more
pain or if they came to understand more
that paying the price of doing the
nine-to-five until you're 65 that price
of having to wake up every morning going
to a job you don't like to impress
people you don't like to work with
people you don't like to get a paycheck
that you don't like that price doing
that for twenty thirty forty years that
price is so heavy and if they were to
take that and stimulate that and put
that into a concept of wow this is gonna
be a painful journey unless I change and
then they focus on let's say investing
on property coming to a crash course
learning those tools learning the
secrets and putting that energy behind
becoming financially free through
property that journey can be sure that
can be a six 12 18 month journey to
being in a place where they never have
to work people get one rejection or they
door they spend six days when they need
to spend six months or 18 months and
they don't get the results that they
want because they watch my financial
freedom challenge in a week or now even
more recently in a day you watch that
right insane the first thing you said in
their program okay we're gonna get
started all I have is my laptop back
yeah and my laptop let's go and then
literally a second later you say I don't
even know where I'm going yeah you know
as long as you trust yourself and you
take action yeah things are gonna happen
you know what it's funny in the in the
Bible I know you're Jewish as well yeah
Old Testament yeah it says about Abraham
it says that Abraham went out not
knowing where he was going in faith and
I think that success in business you do
need faith and faith is seeing the
unseen something that doesn't exist yet
but seeing it
and being prepared to go not know where
you're going because the thing is the
most dangerous position to be standing
is standing still if you're going if
you're moving then you can you can be
guided you can figure things out you can
change direction but if you're standing
still waiting for all the traffic lights
to be on green before you step out the
house you're gonna be there for a very
long time I see that all the time
two people same tools same strategies
same everything one goes out skyrockets
to success the other one not much
happens to them I think it's great to
have tools it's great to have belief it
all boils down to taking action at the
end of the day I believe that the
greatest treasures on planet earth are
reserved for the action takers yeah 100%
and so if you educate yourself you take
the course you take the seminar you read
the book and you combine that with
action success in is inevitable mmm it
is inevitable it's just a question of
time it's you know this I believe
there's no unrealistic goals they're
only unrealistic timelines yeah and so
you know to acquire property like you
said you know whether you're seventeen
eighteen or twenty-one
there's no unrealistic goal there's only
unrealistic timelines I agree with us so
much about action and taking and taking
action to get results and but the thing
is that's why my training programs I
actually make people take action
there and then so it's not like but
other people say I don't want to call
the agent just give me more content just
teach me more no no I'm not teaching you
anything until you picked up the phone
and made that phone call yeah because
that's the best way to learn and
creating an environment people to do
that I'm passionately
[Music]